Jenny you what's that it get me wet
huh Kanye West
you gotta fail oh man his genius first
first of all the way the way I even met
and I did I blew it with I didn't blow
it but it worked out
it's it's cuz I haven't told you the
story but what happened was is that I'm
throwing a party for putt I thought all
these parties in my career so I'm
throwing a party for puss and jay-z's
there and Pharrell is a big party and
this kid walks in with his with a
backpack on and this jaw is busted and I
said who's that and I said that's Kanye
West I said what do you do
it's a he raps and you know he produces
with jay-z I said where everybody comes
to my house got perform I gotta I gotta
see what this dude had so I walked up to
him and I said young man I say you do
your thing you know your rat and he
killed with this freestyle was amazing
so Wow boy you're gonna be famous right
and then he said to me said he said I
have a song that that I think that you
will be great on if week ago I took a
story on their song I said man what I'm
trying to get in the music business
let's go cuz I wasn't in the music biz
and happen to have a studio of my crib
so we go in the back
we heard that yeah but the reason I did
that because I would throw parties for
musical people so I could try to get on
the record
so when jay-z and all them were there
they didn't know go in the studio and he
says the song goes she says she wants a
Marvin Gaye some Luther there's I said I
got it I got I got a she says she wants
some Marvin Gaye and somebody said you
know what are you doing
so well you know you don't know you
don't know R&B see I'm on beef things I
got to put the arms feet bang on this is
I got to do that he said don't do that
just seeing it simple because it's you
know it's hip-hop and I was a high so I
sung it but grudgingly thinking this
song is wack he's not gonna make it it's
not gonna work right so I left and I
went and did a bad movie and I came back
a bad movie and I really did it really
took a chance it was a bad movie I come
back and I'm in Miami and my boy was
like yo remember that song you said was
wack it's number one in the country
Wow and so that's how that's how you get
it wrong but right sometimes yeah that's
it whoo well don't you
[Applause]
[Music]
you